yes Shades why because I'm sparing you
the experience of having to look into my
dull sunken in sickly eyes as I feel
like the immortal words of Han Solo I
feel terrible but as I was clutching my
chicken noodle soup with my DayQuil I
was like I I should do a video on the
Black Panther wakanda forever trailer
and this trailer shows us what we knew
from the last trailer and that is we are
all going to weep I'm gonna weep you're
gonna Weep the person behind you in the
theater is gonna Weep the person three
rows down three seats over gonna weep
I'm sorry I'm so low energy in this
video but this does all come from the
heart all will do it and it'll be a
range it'll be a range between tearing
up and ugly crying and somewhere in
between there you will be I will be we
will be before I talk more about that
let's talk about some of the other
elements of the trailer and like I
always say in these Marvel trailers and
Marvel reviews we're at the Deep Cuts
Like I don't know who nemour is did I
even say it right I kind of hope I said
it wrong Hammer home the points but I
don't know who he is I've heard he's
from Atlantis I heard DC was also like
the [ __ ] he is but he's still apparently
from an underwater civilization at the
legal department assures you that is not
Atlantis you know the thing I liked is
the visual aesthetic the colors pop in
this trailer like the first black
panther you know there are a lot of
sometimes in the world of 4K transfers
and 4K discs movies that are filmed on
digital do not transfer as well as 35
millimeter film does and you see that
with some of the MCU films you're like
well I can't really tell too much of a
difference between the Blu-ray and the
4K black panther looks incredible I love
that Ryan coogler's like we're gonna
make her look [ __ ] killer I mean
let's let's talk about it now let's talk
about Chadwick and and the undeniable
tribute to his life that this movie
looks like it is because we are being
brought in
on an artist's
lamenting the loss of and celebrating
the life of his friend and arguably the
biggest artistic platform this has ever
happened on I mean it's a sequel to a
billion dollar film in the largest film
franchise in cinema history and Ryan
coogler and the team are bringing us the
audience in on the process of
celebrating and crying for Chadwick
Boseman and if I'm being honest I bring
this up because yes because the recast
t'challa movements there's a big part of
me that just I don't want to step in it
but this video being my thoughts that's
part of my thoughts here's how I choose
to see it when Chadwick Boseman passed
most of the world lost an actor or a
character in the MCU an icon all true
but Ryan coogler and the cast lost a
friend I think Chadwick boseman's friend
Ryan coogler knows best how to honor his
friend and I'm going to appreciate him
bringing the audience in on that
grieving process with his art and I'm
also going to choose to see and
appreciate the fact that Ryan coogler
apparently feels that people in the
world would benefit from the release of
experiencing this tribute I imagine the
Multiverse being the Multiverse and
being a huge part of the MCU now I
imagine they will bring in a new
t'challa who's a new actor from Another
Universe among the Multiverse or shuri
or whoever's Black Panther and wakanda
forever is going to crush it and fans
will be like
um I had the eulogy I cried the tears
and I think she's great as Black Panther
and we don't
I feel fulfilled who knows what the
future holds but in terms of my thoughts
on the new trailer for Black Panther
wakanda forever that's pretty much them
so the second trailer to Black Panther
wakanda forever have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]